thank you
[Music]
so did you guys hear what about how Joe
Biden's just had a oofy doofy yeah
like an Air Force Academy of graduation
which was just together right now dude
he'd be falling too much man he feels a
lot what's going on
oh you tripped again do you think he has
the most Falls of all the presidents oh
yeah for sure yeah yeah isn't the full
video that he like walked to the wrong
spot and then had to go back and then
had to go forward and like and then he
fell there's like a hole like Saga well
I mean no there's like the [__] I
have the full video at this point it
just feels like
is Grandpa okay
no yeah he just walked straight walks
right off one step dude that's yeah
Trump nailed him with a [__] goal
that's the full thing the graphic of the
boss it looks defies physics at some
point don't we got like a chief
doctor person that could be like a
physical therapist I think the vice
president needs to take off how old is
he he's like 80. 80. it's about to be 80
something let me see he should probably
do less events huh yeah
he's 80 right now yeah I think he aged
progressively though after um those
Strokes that they kept under the wrap
yeah Strokes he has a couple Strokes
right after the election secret Strokes
he's 80. sounds like cool bands this is
another angle
what do you think
do you think when like people try to
coach him he just tells them like yeah
Trump looks so funny
[Applause]
a lot of people crazy we literally
elected a [__] dude that's in his 80s
yeah well he's now 80. but now I mean
but still like yeah you know like what
the [__] we wanted to see if it was
possible this is like 70 something yeah
70 something that's so old the
difference of sentience is very large 36
76. so by the time if Trump does win
something yeah he'd get elected at 78 I
think I don't know and then finish at
like 81-82 why are we doing this it's
what we do like like I mean Obama was
like he was in his 40s yeah he was young
we want wisdom Reagan was 70 something
yeah he was like the oldest president
until Biden now they didn't Obama retire
at like 55 or something like that yeah
yeah really that's young still yeah
well that's because when he got elected
he was young like like 43 maybe yeah 43.
I hadn't I didn't really because we were
younger so it just felt so old but then
I'm just like can you imagine being like
40 even 40s like five yeah and you're a
[__] present bro that's a big deal
Kennedy was 43. wow Obama people like
the young ones though I mean Kim Jong-un
the dear dear leader sorry black don't
crack
oh he got elected at 47. yeah and
Kennedy was 43. you see a paddle
boarding in Hawaii Obama paddle boarding
and you're like dude this guy's [__]
you still got it bro yeah he still got
it I kind of like having a young
president yeah yeah like a young leader
kind of gives like this younger energy
to the I think Kim Jong-un got started
at 36. how old is he now he's 39. he's
39. yeah well we're the same age that's
so glad they voted for him
so that he won fair Square really yep I
do I do miss having a president that
couldn't calculate on on yeah the
Pillsbury Doughboy right now yeah he's
39. yeah he's 39. I thought he was older
yeah because he looks older yeah yeah
yeah he's very youthful cheeks because
he's a lot taller than I thought like
you know when Trump met him and they
stood stand like stood next to each
other I thought he was gonna be like 5'3
and fat as [__] he's fat as [__] though
he still is but he's not 5'3 I was like
because isn't Trump like six foot or
some [__] so like oh yeah
what do you guys think we uh who should
be president then what can I eat all
right so right now on the right we got
Trump and the Santas right and on the
left we basically have Biden and no
one's contesting except Robert F Kennedy
I like Robert and who else maybe RFK uh
Marion Williamson I don't know but she
has a shot technically there isn't if
there's a sitting president of that
party they don't have a contestant
um
we can't get Robert we can no we we can
but then typically the Democrats
wouldn't back how does Robert
like what would happen is the Democrats
the the most they'll they'll they'll
back the sitting president uh they
wouldn't they should make an exception
this time they should manually
we need her man we need what
change the [__] president out
yeah we got expired eggs in the fridge
[Laughter]
Inspire for a while I think a lot of the
people that voted for Biden they they
thought they were gonna get Obama 2.0
you mean what
there's no [__] way
I want to see him right now how did you
react when when Biden was like if you if
you don't vote for me you're not black
I was like [__] yeah you're not
it is weird how like I mean not to get
so political but like it is weird how
like if you are black you have to be
Democrat you know that is kind of weird
it's like a weird thing yeah yeah in
general yeah like Latinos everybody like
we all like Larry Elder Larry Elder
Larry oh
yeah one of the best politicians to ever
exist
wait is he the guy
yeah
there's a radio guy from combo he was
trying to run for L.A governor no
Governor yes oh and then someone threw
an egg on them yeah someone hit it with
that yeah they were calling him a white
supremacist
that's a hate crime okay walk around I
don't care if you like him or not that's
a hate crime they were calling him a
white supremacist they were yeah yeah
this is the weirdest time right now the
weirdest time this is a good time
because I never thought there'd be a
time when you saw a bunch of white kids
call black people white supremacists oh
it's it's funny because I'm just like
I'd be seeing some of these like out
like protests and stuff right and then
people be arguing and [__] and it'll be
like a bunch of like these like kind of
college students and then they'll be
like a black Republican or conservative
or whatever and they'll be like you
[__] white supremacist I'm like well
they were saying that to even the black
cops that were just holding the line at
the protest yeah like that is so weird
you were just standing there like come
on man that's a good burn though I'm at
work
feelings
oh yeah they're gonna take that
personally
guarding his friend's pawn shop uh and
he got like executed and they were
calling him the same [__]
and he's like a black dude who's like I
mean unless it's Clayton Bixby yeah yeah
unless you got like a Clayton Bixby then
it's like yeah because he was respected
you know he was yeah yeah he had a whole
congregation it's weird like yeah that
younger generation like I just think I
don't know when you think about like us
being that age like we didn't know that
much you know and I think they just
don't know that much true so they think
they know more and no more but they're
just but they're just mad at like
they're mad at like the elderly you know
like people people above them which I
get right you know like that's that
[__] yeah they said like you know The
Angst or whatever yeah because I was I
was a big time communist in high school
because I read this makes me laugh all
right I read the Communist manifestation
a little big Mussolini guy though so
like socialist groups and clubs and [__]
like that it it thrives in like high
school and University because
um
I feel like it makes sense
your Counter Culture you're not
mainstream whatever and then the
ideology just sounds really good like oh
it's awesome you know the world it
sounds really [__] good it's like oh
[__] it sounds like paradise yeah like
everything uh homeboy was saying uh
what's that other old white dude which
one Bernie Sanders Sanders yeah
everything
like everything he was saying
it's like never happened well dude I
used to really like Bernie and then I'm
all like wait a minute you'd be you have
million dollar homes what are you
talking about millionaires you're a
millionaire
he really does talk about both sides of
his mouth on all the war stuff yeah and
all the he just supports the corporate
his Democrats on everything yeah
it's kind of like
you know that Black Mirror episode where
the guy makes that viral video yeah yeah
what the [__] yeah why you gotta talk
about that yeah is it cushion poster
that you're talking about no because I'm
trying to connect he goes uh have you
guys seen Black Mirror you know that
episode where the where the where the
where the guy it's that it's that
episode when they're all in the tower
and they're doing they're like a rat in
the cage just doing the same thing right
and he makes a viral video and then he
gets famous for men so he gets invited
to the upper class and then to do uh to
do that viral video but he I think he
was like it was like a suicide video or
some [__] like he had a knife and he was
he had his monologue and they're like oh
it's so passionate right and when he got
to the top he wanted to be this like
Rebel and disrupt the system and
everything and then he was like you know
what life is kind of good at the top
yeah and then he just started performing
his thing and all that and then he just
stayed up there and it was kind of like
I kind of feel like that's what people
do right like politics and all that
everyone has this energy to change the
world and then they get there and then
they're like
actually well even yeah that's true like
I feel that like that that younger
generation that's like highly upset like
wants all these like you know fantasy
things I think it's just like a lot of
it becomes from like yeah they just
broke you know when you think about it
like because when you get money yeah
things do change your life does change
when you have a consistent flow of a lot
of money yeah things are [__] very
different and you're not gonna complain
about the things that you would normally
complain about yeah yeah you know when
you think about it like I just think
it's like yeah like more like a classist
thing than it is like it's classic then
it is like a racism like you know I
think yeah racism it happens when like
you're someone that's not benefiting
from the system so you hate the system
but then as you work in the system and
then you benefit from the system you're
like I kind of like the system now
it's got a sweet for sure yeah like
caviar that's why it's hard to blame all
these [__] hack-ass news anchors
right because they're living the life
making like 30 grand a week yeah getting
to they make that much oh yeah they're
killing it and it's a Cooper yeah
exactly
yeah kill him it makes millions and
millions plus historically like when you
look at countries that did have
revolutionaries that took over like that
usurped the government how did that turn
out always disaster the rebels always
become the institution yeah that's I
feel like the new corrupt basically
disruption power struggle and then the
new establishment like
it's like a cycle it's like having
winter spring summer fall whatever and
it just keeps going on and on because if
you think about America this like well
Rebel State we don't have royalty and
then like we become the biggest empire
right and then like there's gonna be new
disruptors there's going to be new
Rebels and it's going to keep cycling
like this Rebels will always become the
new institution until another group of
rebels come and become the and disrupt
this one corruption right we we will
take corrupt people and we will actually
use them right if they serve our
American interests like how many people
in Afghanistan are acting all that stuff
they're they were the bad guys right and
then we use them as informants we pardon
everything that they did bad and like
you know it's like the show The
Blacklist right like that's about that's
about like a bunch of bad guys right
because bad guys and you say you people
[Laughter]
and then he's like hey you forgive all
my crimes I'll tell you guys where all
the [__] pudding is made and they're
like all right dude damn that's all yeah
same thing in Dark Knight Rises there's
like a similar lesson
foreign